so I've been of the course but I've been
wanting and I think that it was achieved
for the greater part is to have students
become very analytical when it comes to
the use of language race religion gender
as technologies technologies to create
hierarchies of of power and and but if
you think of something that 7 Biko once
said because one said that the most
efficient tool of the oppressor is the
mind of the of the oppressed so Altidore
is to understand how when you grow up in
a society where there are various Iraqis
that are imposed on that society based
on tools like how we perceive race how
we perceive language varieties that we
perceive gender how we perceive religion
and we ourselves both myself as a
faculty at MIT but also the students us
as students coming from different social
groupings we bring those those Iraqis
with us and often it's implicit not
aware of that so I didn't of the course
one thing which became clear to me that
the students became more aware of how
these cultural phenomena and in the use
of them in the position of them are used
as tools to maintain those Iraqis so
what became clear to me that towards in
of the course the students were indeed
very self-conscious of those of the uses
of of culture of race of religion of
issues about migration in creating those
those walls and and I think now they
have tools that we can use to bring
those walls within themselves but also
within the social groups